hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Pixar inside out review in case
you guys haven't seen it what I'm gonna
do is like the first half of the video
will be non spoilery and then the second
half I'll do spoilers so here we go one
of the things I love most about Pixar
films is that they're not afraid to try
new ideas and this is like one of the
newest weirdest ideas that they've had
for a movie
most of the voice cast you'll probably
recognize the main cast is really the
five different emotions joy sadness
disgust anger and fear most of the
trailers feature Amy Poehler if she's
she's pretty much like the point girl in
the movie but the film is built around
all five emotions on one level it's a
lot like the Toy Story films and that
it's about learning that it's okay for
things to change as you grow up but on a
deeper level this movie is a lot more
about learning and development and how
that changes as you grow up so it's
taking a much more internalized view of
growing up
climatic aliy I mean if you are gonna
tie this to a franchise though I would
tie it to Toy Story because Pete docter
the director also wrote inside out he's
the same guy that wrote all the Toy
Story films or I should say that he
wrote the original story that the Toy
Story movies were based on there's a
difference between the story in the
screenplay
I mean it's a bunch of different things
but creatively the Toy Story franchise
and Inside Out flow from the same place
so if you like Toy Story you'll like
this but it's much more cerebral in the
sense that it focuses much more on the
action inside your head then on think
that the physical actions you take in
the real world so it's almost literally
reflexive in a way that the Toy Story
movies aren't like the toys and Toy
Story think about their own existence as
toys which it was just kind of funny and
ironic at the same time the movies does
try really hard to explain the feedback
loop of you know actions leading to
emotions leading to long-term memories
in those memories influencing future
actions and even though it's so heavy on
emotions I didn't find it too
emotionally manipulative this isn't Game
of Thrones with memories there has been
a lot of talk about how the film
portrays depression because that's a big
arc in the film the proposition you
begin with is that the joy is like the
most pure great emotion you could feel
and depression and sadness is the
opposite of that that's why you see Amy
Poehler and Phyllis Smith so much in the
trailer sadness she's one of those
actresses that you know you've heard
before but you just can't place them she
played Phyllis on the office without
getting too heavy into the story the
film does do a good job of
of explaining the relationship between
these two seemingly polar opposite
emotions the real weirdness the film
comes from some of the really big things
that it's missing and actually think
that's a good thing I should say you
know weirdness and that it's good weird
typically most stories involve an
antagonist and a protagonist this film
is not like that so it might seem a
little bit weird in that there's no like
big villain to defeat a really good
contrast for this is Avengers age of
Ultron they did sequences where you go
inside the Avengers minds and they have
to deal with these really strange pseudo
memories it's very weird and unexpected
in a movie where you expect a lot of
punching and kicking and even though
that's not really what Pixar films are
about that there is a lot of like
punching and kicking going on inside the
Toy Story films but there is a villain
inside Toy Story 3 trying to hurt the
good toys and that's not really how the
narrative and inside-out is constructed
and I think that's a really good thing
this is the kind of film that you might
end up watching inside like a high
school psychology class or like an intro
college class I mean a lot of it's very
whimsical but a lot of the ideas are
solid like the way that memories are
stored the way memories change on all
I'll give the movie a giant thumbs up I
mean you don't need to see it in 3d or
imax or anything like that it totally
works just in regular 2d and a lot of my
extra praise for the film goes in the
fact that Pixar was willing to try
something this weird that should give
you a lot of hope for the other big
franchises at Disney like Marvel and
Star Wars I mean you know a lot of it is
like recycling franchises but then every
once in a while they slip in a film like
this something that's just so weird and
different that it feels like it doesn't
fit right away really where it starts to
fit is when you think of Pixar films in
the context of what it's like to be a
child and grow up that I mean that's
really what those films are about but
just to get into spoilers so I'm gonna
talk about a couple of my favorite
moments in the film so careful if you
haven't seen the movie yet here we go
far and away my favorite part of the
film was when they make it to
Imaginationland and they run into Bing
bong he's played by Richard kind he is
the perfect voice of an imaginary friend
just the right amount of crazy energy
like oh my god he's a lunatic but this
seems like it might be fun it also
doesn't hurt that he cries candy I
honestly I don't think a lot of the
emotional arc of the film would have
worked without his sacrifice he in a way
is like one of the smartest characters
in the film because he comes to terms
with his own existence in the way that
Riley like the little
girl hasn't yet to be fair though you
don't really expect a little kid to
figure that out
when she hasn't even hit puberty yet the
puberty console was a nice end tag like
oh my god I wonder what this big red
button does for the most part like the
other emotions besides joy and sadness
they were fairly forgettable I mean you
know Bill Hader Louis black Mindy Kaling
they're all great actors but they didn't
really become interesting until that end
tag - you know what you started to see
the blended emotions like fear and joy
at the same time even though it's an
overly simplistic way to view emotions I
thought it worked the film just says
emotions are extremely complex you can
feel a number of them in the same
instance although if you really want to
get scientific about it there are a lot
of biochemical processes associated with
forming memories and learning and
development that they they just kind of
left out it's almost like the whole film
is taking place inside the room of
abstract thought because it's presenting
these emotions as distinct things in an
abstract way so I guess that's probably
the best way to think about it that's an
even better way of describing the
process by which I make videos like I
feel like I'm sitting inside a room of
abstract dot it feels completely weird
until I turn around I start editing the
video but here's my big question for you
guys what was your favorite part of the
film and do you want to see them try
more weird ideas like this that is to
say films that don't necessarily have a
main villain to overcome and resolutions
that are kind of ambiguous like oh life
is gonna be complicated and I'll deal
with it as opposed to say like a Marvel
movie where it's like I punch you you're
dead I win BAM movie over for those of
you asking like what Pixar movies are
coming up next so the good dinosaur is
their next movie that's coming this
November it's like the alternate history
tale about like what happens if the
earth didn't get hit by a giant
meteorite
then there's finding Dory that's like
the next Finding Nemo movie part of that
franchise so expect a lot of those
actors to come back that's next year
then Toy Story 4 so you know a couple
franchise movies back to back there is
an Incredibles 2 I have yet to meet a
person that did not like that film it
did a great job of deconstructing the
superhero genre I don't know how they're
gonna follow that up so we'll see my
expectations typically get lowered for
sequels really I think what we're
waiting for is a really badass Pixar
Marvel collaboration on an animated
movie they do have big hero 6 but that's
really like a Disney anime
Marvel collaboration and that feels much
more like a Disney film than it does
like a Marvel film the closest thing we
have to that is the Incredibles
franchise and Toy Story they're both
really good but I feel like it'd be
really awesome to see Marvel characters
go through some sort of story arc like
you see in those films what does it mean
to be a superhero like we need an inside
out for Tony Stark
that would be a nightmare the whole
movie would be that giant clown from the
subconscious stomping around with a
liquor bottle trying to chase you so
moving down the line ant-man Fantastic
Four a couple other big movies coming
this summer so I'll be doing videos for
that be sure to subscribe to get them if
there's any other movies that you want
me to do videos for just let me know in
the comments but well you guys wait for
that you can click here for my Jurassic
world review probably one of the better
films of the summer is a lot of fun
maybe not quite as good as Mad Max but
you can click here to learn all about
some of the cast members the Game of
Thrones season 6 is looking for right
now thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you